so okay so a lot of the governor's
around this country do not want Syrian
refugees in their state made that plain
if you were the governor right now what
would your position on we've been we've
been accepting Syrian refugees in
California we have 252 without incident
for over the last couple years we've
accepted tens of thousands of refugees
over the course the last few decades
that have assimilated extraordinarily
well in California one thing we're not
going to do is we're not going to play
the politics of fear we're not going to
turn our back on people that have been
persecuted turn our back on people that
have been threatened by terror we're not
going to sort of play the xenophobic
game of trying to one-up Republican
governors and we're certainly not going
to but what is the number you say 252 I
did not in any no 11 percent of one
percent of the what the country's so far
and we've got he wants to put 10,000
California will do it but there is some
number that would be too many right
Germany wants to accept upwards of a
million would that be too many yeah I
mean perhaps but the bottom line is
whatever we do whatever the number is
it's a vetting process and right now it
takes 18 to 24 months to be vetted and
50% of people have been rejected in this
country the 2000 that we have allowed in
the vast majority are women and children
and seniors and so with respect what's
amazing to me about this debate bill and
it really is amazing is the idea that
terrorists need to wait two years to be
get Asylum status versus just getting a
plane ticket and getting on an airplane
because we have a visa waiver program in
this country 20 million people take
advantage of the terrorists in France in
Belgium were national citizens of France
and Belgium and they could come over we
want to close that loophole senator
Feinstein's got to do that 2016 weed is
on the ballot gonna be I'm about it
you're for that we it's long overdue to
tax and regulate for values came about
from a Blue Ribbon Commission yes I'm
not on it
because we knew your position well in
events will it pass this time I think it
will pass Ohio was badly crafted
legislation that was monopolistic and
Ohio did not have a medical system in
place like Colorado Washington Oregon
California had a medical system since
1996 a mature system and I'm absolutely
confident that we can do it in the right
way and will give the voters of
California opportunity to do it ex I no
question El Ninos coming will it solve
our drought probably not going to solve
in a one year no I wish it would oh
but the hots are getting hotter the
colds are getting colder the wets are
getting wetter and that's a reason that
perhaps the most important meeting
that's happening the next month and this
is out there in Paris with the climate
talks we got to get serious about
climate all right
you